KENNETH CALVERT: The history
of the Roman Republic
is a cautionary tale.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We are going on a journey
that will teach us
a great many things
about a free society.
CARL YOUNG: The
Roman Republic was
one of the finest
systems of government
that the world has ever known.
The reason we should
study the ancients
is because it makes us
better human beings.
KENNETH CALVERT: In the
progressive modern world,
we want to think that human
beings can be perfected.
But really, what
history teaches us
is that we're the same people.
If we, as a free
society, think that we
are facing unusual
tensions and events,
you've got to understand
that there were mobs in Rome.
There was all kinds of
trouble that they were facing.
We don't have to be Rome.
We learned from
the Roman Republic
the lessons of citizenship,
the lessons of tyranny,
and what it all means
for a free society
to face difficult
times, particularly
if those difficult times are
a result of their own success.
CARL YOUNG: The histories
are themselves a kind
of moral education, a
political education.
We, as a nation, would
be far better off
if we spent more of our
time studying those examples
from Roman history.
LARRY P. ARNN: Why
should you take the time
to study these old and
complicated things?
The answer is it's the best
single thing you can do.
KENNETH CALVERT: The study
of the Roman Republic
is really one of the
most important things
we can do as Americans.
Our founders-- Washington,
Jefferson, Adams, Madison--
all studied the Roman
Republic as they
created the American republic.
It's very important for
us to understand why.
This is our course on
the Roman Republic.
Let's begin.